hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be delving
into the newest developments in the
black clover story
including yuno's epic new form and
transformation an intense rematch
between xenon and yuno
and much more the final battle in this
incredible spate kingdom war arc is now
well underway
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
black clover content here on the channel
and you want us to keep it going you
know what to do
leave a like and comment it really does
help
and if you're new to anime outbreak or
maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video do subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on
all notifications seriously if you like
our videos and you want to actually be
notified you have to go through the
trouble of clicking that bell and then
selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos even
if you are subscribed it's just how
youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram
at anime uproar finally this video will
of course contain black clover manga
spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned
the previous installment of the story
ended with the three different groups of
infiltrators
each confronting one of the three
members of the dark triad
each of the three groups had three
members but
one of those members served as a decoy
to distract the dark disciples while the
other two made their way
directly to their respective target the
latest chapter focuses specifically on
yuno and languras confronting xenon
and let me tell you it is definitely as
epic as we were all hoping that it would
be
nosel silva who had been with yuno and
language initially
is presumably keeping xenon's dark
disciples busy
while yuno and language confront xenon
himself as we know
both xenon and yuno are men of few words
so after xenon expresses surprise that
yuno is still alive and after yuno
explains that he is alive thanks to
william
and that he intends to get william back
the battle begins
right away not a lot of chit chat not a
lot of talk no jutsu
just down to business yuno starts things
off with a piercing wind attack
and xenon blocks it using his bone magic
at this point xenon is very confident
that he is going to defeat yuno without
much problems
but yuno is not alone langris joins the
fray by launching his
archangel shoot down spell at xenon
this spell creates a bunch of spatial
magic spheres that fly at the enemy and
erase
anything that touches them but xenon is
able to stop langer's spheres by sealing
each and every one of them
inside his own spatial magic cubes
xenon basically counters spatial magic
with even stronger spatial magic
because his magic is able to dominate
the mana within
any space that it encompasses and
despite successfully countering his
attack
xenon actually praises langus's
abilities and said that if it wasn't for
him
langris would probably be the strongest
spatial magic user
but langris isn't distracted by xenon's
words he prepares to launch an even
stronger spatial magic spell called
archangel annihilation but before that
spell can hit its designated target
xenon uses a spell called spatial
domination
to create a massive spatial magic cube
that encompasses the entire hallway
this means that all three of them xenon
yuno and langris
are now located within the spatial magic
cube
that xenon has just created xenon
explains that a mage who enters this
space
cannot use any of their spells and since
both yuno and langris are already within
the space
xenon is confident that he is about to
kill them both right here and now
but that is when yuno unleashes his
secret weapon
he summons self aka bell use a spirit
dive
and unlocks a new transformation called
spirit of
boreas in his new form yuno has a full
crown
and a halberd which is a long spear-like
weapon that has both a spear tip
and a battle axe edge i have to say that
yuno's new form looks freaking awesome
and this form is definitely befitting of
the rightful spade kingdom ruler
the fact that juno's crown is now
complete suggests that he has now
learned to perform spirit dive with
belle
more effectively he has been able to
merge with her and her mana on a more
complete level
and that is why this form appears to be
more complete than his previous
spirit dive incarnation and that is why
it appears to be much stronger as well
i really like the fact that juno now has
a unique weapon of his own
osta's got his swords which are super
cool and now yuno's got his magical
shiny halberd that gives him a true
royal heir i also loved seeing yuno
standing up to xenon and vowing to get
revenge for his former defeat
after all yuno is still competing to
become the new wizard king it's not just
asta who wants to make this happen so
yuno can't become the wizard king unless
he defeats all of his enemies
and that includes xenon thanks to bell
and the spirit dive
yuno is able to overcome xenon's
absolute space spell
because he is loved by the mana of that
space
and so apparently this cancels out the
effects
of xenon's spell that's a turn of events
that genuinely surprises xenon
and that is no small feat because xenon
is not a man who is easily surprised
and so even though he is fighting inside
of xenon's huge
absolute space cube yuno is still able
to use his magic
and he proceeds to use that new epic
halberd to pierce through
xenon's bone magic shield juno's attack
actually manages to tear a large hole
in xenon's chest as xenon looks at his
own wound in shock
the awakened you know appears to have
won the fight and that is how this
chapter ends but not so fast despite
those last few panels of the chapter
there is no way that xenon has been
defeated so quickly we've already seen
both dante and vanica recover from even
worse wounds
multiple times so we should expect that
xenon will do the same
however the very fact that yuno was able
to land
such a blow on xenon in the first place
is a big deal
and as we see xenon himself is more
shocked
than anyone yuno is now significantly
stronger than he was the last time that
he and xenon fought
but does that mean that juno is actually
strong enough to defeat
xenon now i highly doubt that and that
is why langris is there to back yuno up
and even with language there once xenon
recovers from his injury and uses
80 percent of his devil's power yuno and
languras will still be outmatched
so that is why i think that yuno and
language have some other ace
up their sleeve i think that someone
else is going to show up and help them
fight xenon
including of course nozelle once he's
done dealing with the dark disciples
and potentially even mario leona after
she's done with the giant demon
outside the palace this chapter served
an important purpose
we needed to see yuno actually land this
surprise hit on xenon
because tabata wanted us to know just
how much stronger
yuno has become however actually
defeating xenon for good is a different
matter
altogether and that won't be so easy
knowing tabitha
this battle will involve a lot more
nuance than just
langris and yuno overpowering xenon
because oh hey
they both trained really hard i think
that we will see
a lot more mages joining the fight i
think that we will see a lot of teamwork
and strategy
and in the end asta's anti-magic will
end up being the key to taking down the
dark
triad so yeah i know that some people
out there will complain that yuno
shouldn't have gotten so strong so
quickly but you have to understand that
up to this point xenon was
underestimating yuno xenon was confident
in his victory and he didn't take yuno
or langris seriously
but now things have changed xenon knows
who he's dealing with and he is about to
go all
out in the next few chapters that is
when we will get to see what yuno and
language are truly made of
and it is my opinion that nozelle and
other mages will have to join the fight
and a lot of strategy and teamwork will
ultimately be involved
in taking xenon down it will definitely
not be an easy
fight or a quick fight but let me know
what you guys think
do you like yuno's new form and are you
impressed by how strong he has become do
you think that juno's new form will be
strong enough to actually take xenon out
or do you agree with me that we are
about to see a long and difficult battle
and that victory will require a lot more
than just yuno's new form
knowing what we know about xenon and his
two magic attributes
how do you think he will ultimately be
defeated will it be asta who takes him
down
or will yuno and the others figure out a
way to do it without asta
don't forget to share your thoughts down
in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more blacklover content right
here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you're new to
animeopro or maybe you just haven't
subscribed
make this the video do you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also follow me
on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar big thank you to all of
our anime outpour
patrons for making videos like this one
possible
special thank you to alpha sigma a
disciple of lord twego
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one
tier patrons the ones rise above all
other clans
including ingrata the world a quiet
respect
liam thompson pate heffa ruthean yx
phoenix anime 987 emperor otaku thomas
jones
spidey life danelle baked buddhist
tungsten tarkis
and denki kaminari finally thank you
also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica calefon
alicia
octor bonnie parks hinokamian water the
red-haired raven
florian joanne garcia jack watches anime
fat boy games deadly saint matthew crews
and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you please consider supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar gives
you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time
see ya cowboys
you